presentó el ex vicepresidente Mike pence
todos los papeles necesarios a la
comisión federal electoral
estadounidense y el anuncio oficial lo
haría este miércoles también hay que
mencionar que penss desafía no solamente
a Donald Trump sino que en ocasiones
pasadas pues se ha cuestionado el papel
que jugó el expresidente en La Toma a el
Capitolio el 6 de enero de 2021 pensa
además ha dicho en varias entrevistas
que no apoyaría a Donald Trump en caso
de que Donald Trump fuera nuevamente
votado como candidato a la presidencia
por el partido republicano hay que
mencionar que penss tiene 63 años Fue
gobernador del estado de Indiana después
congresista y ex vicepresidente de
Donald Trump quien ahora pues es su
contrincante en las encuestas Mike pence
está detrás no solamente de Donald Trump
que está liderando las encuestas para
esta primaria republicana sino también
detrás
el gobernador de la Florida y pues
también potencial contrincante de Donald
Trump en estas primarias hay que
mencionar que en cuanto a la
financiación
el vicepresidente ya tiene un pack un
pack súper pack que es un grupo de
financiación acá en Estados Unidos como
lo llaman que se llama comprometidos por
América en todo caso el vicepresidente
Está tratando de marcar diferencia con
Donald Trump para poder en Iowa
concentrar su campaña ganar ese estado
que es el primer estado en las primarias
en todas las primarias de el país y
quedarse en ese estado con el voto el
voto evangélico que es por donde quiere
enfocar su Campaña en io va a estar
visitando mucho el estado de ávido a
precisamente para apelar a ese voto y
quedarse y dar ese golpe primario que es
tan importante en las elecciones en
Estados Unidos las reacciones han sido
por un lado buenas por otro lado Pues de
cuestionamiento porque los radicales los
que están en con Donald Trump lo voy a
ir como un traidor pero los republicanos
de Centro ven es su precandidatura como
una oportunidad para el partido
republicano